z asks if you were to jump in a time  machine  travel back to speak to your 21 year old  self and only have one minute what do  you say Z I would tell that person to  hook up with more chicks and not work as  many hours and I know that can be crass  and I and obviously you know what what  that crass statement is really saying is  have a little more fun right you're  gonna accomplish your things you're  gonna pull it off you know we appreciate  that you do have business patience but  you need to spend a little bit more time  with your friends you can go on one more  vacation you can go do a keg stand you  need to live a little bit because you're  gonna have a family which is gonna be  amazing  you're gonna be busy as crap and you're  gonna run out of this time you're only  21 once oh crap wait subscribe I need  subscriptions because I can't push this  many right hooks in social so subscribe